the subcommittee meeting for HB 81 and
we have we had five subcommittee members
assigned I see we have three of them
here which makes it a quorum so we can
go ahead and vote later on today we have
uh representative Bernardi to my left
and representative Summers to my right
and we have chairman Bose here at the
time and also representative merner as
well
uh the purpose of the subcommittee
basically is to discuss HB 81 which was
a request to form a sub to form a study
committee to study the all of the fees
that are associated with I guess propane
industry in the state so that's the
basis of this bill uh representative
partial has joined us so we
here so and he's part of our
subcommittee so well represented and so
that's the purpose of of this
subcommittee uh I understand we have
industry Representatives here uh and I
would invite them to introduce
themselves Mr Scully if you'd like to
start and uh and do that I also
recognize representative wrong who's the
Prime sponsor of the bill has just
arrived as well so if you want to start
the introductions and then we just just
thank you
I would ask my chairman of those at the
public hearing if I had contacted the
consumer Bureau and the Department of
Justice I have a problem that I do have
of listing of all the complaints that
was a child with the attorney general by
uh
you just uh representative Bernardi will
serve as a clerk of the subcommittee as
well so just pass it to him and then
with all the introductions done I will
uh invite
um
AmeriGas whichever one wants to speak to
come to the mic and uh we've we've been
told that you have something to say so
we'll have your say so first and then
after we discussed the AmeriGas
issues here we'll open it up for
questions for general questions in
involving fees in the state and how
they're how they're developed how
they're assigned who has them who
doesn't have them why they do why they
don't are some mandated by uh Federal uh
policy are some just because in business
you have to have them all that type of
stuff so with that I will invite who's
going to speak
okay
sure
absolutely
and just make sure you turn the mic on
before we start I'll just say my my
disclaimer is that I am a propane gas
user for my home heating oil with Palmer
Gas and Oil in case anyone is interested
okay
um again
thank you for giving AmeriGas the
opportunity to come in and uh let us
share a little bit about our company
with you and a little bit of our history
and sort of where we're going to go and
we um really appreciate
um please ask us questions if you have
questions if maybe we say something that
you don't understand or you would like a
little bit more information I'm going to
give a really quick overview just to
give you a little bit more background on
the company the company is headquartered
in King of Prussia Pennsylvania which is
about 20 miles outside of Philadelphia
we have been in business since 1959 we
do service all 50 states we have about
1.3 million customers and those
customers can be residential heat
customers residential gas or residential
gas nerve customers they can be
commercial customers agricultural
customers commercial customers whether
it's a small pizza shop or use a
shipping company that uses propane for
for motor fuel
um we do have district offices and
almost all 50 states not in all of them
and we have are from a from a leadership
our leadership team does sit in King of
Prussia Pennsylvania and then we have
through our management team we have
division vice presidents which Jim
pakovic here is one of the division vice
presidents he oversees basically the
central part of the country as well as
the eastern part of the country right
now we also have someone like him
working on our Western and then
underneath from a management structure
we have our director of territory
operations and they can be responsible
for several States
and Victor is one of Esperanza is our
director of territory operations that
covers New Hampshire for example and
these guys know Victor and then within
we have territory managers that run
specific districts or the day-to-day
operations of of the propane we've sort
of heard that propane really is just
taking gas from a big tank and putting
it into a smaller tank sometimes it can
be challenging to do that but that's
really what we do and as well as
servicing our customers
several years ago pre-covet we did
change our sort of business model a
little bit looking to go more online we
were seeing more of our customers wanted
to go online and deal with us
electronically and so we did go away
from what I think has been historically
a traditional propane District model
where your manager and the customer
relations representative is sitting in
the district we centralized our
operations and so now we have
centralized distributions centralized
procurement as well as our call centers
and we have a couple of call centers
around the country that when a customer
calls in it's one number they reach a
trained customer experience agent and we
have a customer relations management
system that allows them to go in and so
any agent can answer a phone call from
any customer across the company
while that sounds very easy it was
challenging in 2019 to go through that
experience while we were setting up
those call centers during covid and then
as we were sort of coming out of it in
2021 2022 sort of hit us a little bit
more and we have been having I think
like others in the industry and outside
the industry some staffing shortages so
we were having driver shortages we were
having service tech shortages not just
in New Hampshire but company-wide and we
were also bringing on new employees so
whereas a lot of employees have been in
the propane business for 10 20 and 30
years we were seeing on the good side we
were seeing new people coming to the
propane industry which was always good
but I mean if I may end up I I do have
one question going back to your
statement about you went to a more of an
online business now in
particularly in New England but
especially in New Hampshire we have an
older population and where people are
located in more rural areas I'm sure
they're using outdoor propane tanks
most of those people are not in their
20s or 30s so was there any problem with
when you went to a more of an online
business model do do they know
how to get in contact with you because
even though they they may have a
computer maybe they're not they're not
used to going online for things like
that I'm I'm just kind of interested
because that might be a might be one
issue that we may not even know about
about online type of stuff so I don't
have our specific customer breakdown of
unless you know of online versus
um but they're still the traditional
it's still a 1 800 number that you can
pick up and call and you will get a live
person and so the what if you were a
propane customer from five years ago for
example and you had the number to your
local district office that number now
automatically rolls in so even if you
were dialing an old number it's going to
roll into the 1-800 number that is still
going to get you a live person you do
not need to be online in any way to do
business with AmeriGas if you would
prefer to have your statement mailed to
you to call in and be if you're a will
call customer call to make your order
absolutely that's has stayed the same or
you even if you want to do a little bit
of a blend you can do a little bit
online but still do a little bit over
the phone that still exists or if you
want to do completely online customers
um
so so sort of moving forward oh and what
I handed you is again sort of a customer
fact sheet that shows our current
customers in the state of New Hampshire
and our district offices where they
serve out so where the bobtails come in
they'll pick up the gas and they go out
and make deliveries and then the packet
what I gave you is our new customer
welcome packet so every customer when
they become a customer of AmeriGas will
get this packet and it includes our
terms and conditions which is basically
the same version of our residential
customer agreement that a customer could
sign online or they can do it we would
mail it out to the customer if they
didn't want the online experience it
would we would mail it out to the
customer they could sign it and send it
back
and and then again the t's and C's that
are in there is basically the same as
the residential agreement so what that
that lays out is the relationship
between the company and the customer so
in those t's and C's we do disclose you
know how the uh what is the cut what is
customer equipment what is Amerigas
equipment what our fees and charges are
so the customer can see that before they
become a customer of AmeriGas and those
terms and conditions have been online at
least since 2012 that I know of for sure
but probably
um even before that so if a customer is
looking at do it shopping around they
can go online to amerigasa's website and
all of that is available online for them
to see what the charges would be if they
were to become a customer
so that's what's in front of you then um
just to go back
um again this this particular year
obviously we don't ever want any
customer to find it difficult to get in
touch with us that's why we wanted to
shift our our model so that that anybody
um any customer could call at any time
and get a live person and they can walk
them through and and help them deal with
whether they wanted a delivery whether
they had a service issue they didn't
understand something on the bill that
really was the goal and the aim of what
we were trying to do and have very
systematic training so that every
customer had the same experience so this
year in particular we we know that we
had some issues coming with our call
centers and so we've been really
training our call centers to be able to
do two primary things one is to answer
the phone as quickly as they can
um that is actually the easy part then a
little more challenging is to answer the
customer with what they need with one
call resolution and then if they're not
where we've seen there has been a little
bit of a breakdown is is following up
reaching back out to the customer making
sure you were resolving that customer
issue so they don't have to call
multiple times so what we've been doing
to immediately deal with that issue is
in particular when we when we heard a
little bit more about this one is we
created a specific call queue for New
Hampshire so customers in New Hampshire
right now are calling in to only our
senior level cxa agents at the moment
cxa is customer experience agent and
we're going through and so they have we
upgraded the scripts the telephone
scripts to make sure they had more
information to better be able to answer
the customers questions and really get
to that one call resolution
we also looked at and our our primary
goal during the winter is always
delivery excuse me
so we have had some of our service tax
that normally we do tank pickups for
example or other routine service work
they are in bobtails making deliveries
so some of our service work we did see
began to lag behind what we would even
consider acceptable levels so we did see
that tank pickups did lag behind so in
working with our service department we
have now engaged a third party vendor to
assist us in picking up any outstanding
tanks that needs to be picked up and we
changed we know specifically there has
been
um
we needed to clarify our policy on
underground tanks and we've historically
had because a lot of our customers who
have underground tanks or acquisition
customers our company has really grown
through buying other companies and
growing through Acquisitions and Records
don't always transfer easily so we may
not get a customer file from someone who
is a customer of Michelle's propane from
20 years ago so we don't know what the
original Arrangement was with an
underground tank
so we put in our T's and C's which have
been there for a while that if you have
an underground tank it is a customer's
responsibility to pay for the removal we
know and that we generally were not
selling our underground tank because
steel is an asset for us but we've now
changed that policy in New Hampshire so
I believe we have 26 tanks underground
tanks that need to be picked up what
we're going to do is negotiate
individually with the customers and sell
them the underground tank so that there
doesn't have to be a disruption to the
property but if they don't want to buy
the tank we will go ahead once the
weather permitting and pick it up for me
I have a question at this point could
you go into a little more I I might know
the answer but could you go into a
little more detail on
the underground tanks and why you do
what you do and why don't you just take
them over and uh without any issues and
and things like that
uh
well I'll explain sort of then I don't
know if you want to jump in sorry unless
representative could you clarify the
question exactly what are you looking
for on the Underground well uh there's
the statement that you made that you
that you did some changes
um and that you're not you're going to
sell sell the underground tanks back to
the customer uh but issues uh about uh
transfer or
or buying and selling the tanks what
what goes into that why why
um
I got uh why is it more difficult than
just a simple buy and sell transfer or
why even sell them why don't you just
keep on using them
so okay I'll do my best to answer that
question
so a lot to unpack there but
um so underground assets as my
colleagues behind me uh no I mean that's
it's there's a lot of effort and time
that goes into putting in those
particular assets and typically once a
customer has that asset the last thing
they want to be doing is digging up
their property so in the past and
certainly in current situations even
today if a customer calls uh and they
want to exit business with AmeriGas or
even our counterparts if there's nothing
we can absolutely do to cure that
relationship with that customer what
we'll typically offer an opportunity for
them to either buy that asset we may
exchange an asset an underground tank
with with our with our competitors
whether it's here in New Hampshire or
anywhere for that matter or if push
comes to shove we can certainly work
with customer to remove that asset
um and and either have somebody else
another underground asset or they may
choose to go above ground but the
underground asset is is certainly a more
complex installation versus a typical
residential installation where you might
have a vertical dot a tank across this
next to the house a 500 gallon of above
ground that's outside the house and in
this part of the country which I was
raised in in this industry this time of
year is very difficult as well sometimes
to pull those out although it is 50
degrees here today you know there are
times certainly when I started this
business in 98 that those tanks would be
frozen for for the entire winter so you
would work with the customer uh if they
so choose to want to take their business
elsewhere we would make arrangements to
remove that asset once the winter season
was over does that answer your question
or did I well as as a follow-up
um uh I'll ask a question this way uh I
have an underground tank
it came with the house
it's approximately 17 18 years old
let's say there's an issue with the tank
some I don't know what what could be
going wrong but let's say there's an
issue with the tank
my gas company comes I assume I call
them they come to fix it
do I pay for it
is
it they assumed they they assumed
ownership of the tank when I when I
purchased the home it was a new home at
the time it was a 18 months old the tank
originally belonged to Eastern uh I
wanted Palmer Gas as my own
um and uh Palmer says yeah you're a
great customer we knew you in Salem we
sold your oil we'll sell you gas here
and they said that they would take over
ownership of the tank as far as I know
never had to look into it after that it
was like a transparent transfer no
issues so my assumption is that they
took over ownership of the tank yeah so
what I would say is generally speaking
um if it is a tank that is owned by the
company repairs that pertain to the tank
are sort of piping even probably up to
the second stage regulator the company
would take care of generally speaking
thank you oh take my question and this
is actually a follow-up on that I have
an underground tank as well but I
noticed we looked at the bill the
complaints we were having some of them
were the fact of uh
when they had complaints with their gas
company they were told that they can
shop around in fact we heard that today
we can they can shop around
but if they have an in-ground tank like
myself so if I'm upset with my vendor
and I have there in the green ground
tank that was built in most of the new
homes in New Hampshire are getting in
ground tanks and I wanted to switch to
Amerigas
um
they own it what's the what's involved
in transferring it do I have to pay to
have so just to change companies do I
need to pay for the a brand new tank do
I need to pay for the digging up of the
one I have now what's involved for me
and what I'm going to say is generally
speaking first it would be whatever was
in if if you had an original contract so
if let's say for example that you became
I'm going to use AmeriGas you became an
AmeriGas customer you have a new home
you want an underground tank for
aesthetic or other reasons we would have
a contract with you saying okay it's
going to be an AmeriGas take AmeriGas is
going to put it in the ground these are
the charges that would go with that and
then there would be a provision that
would say and if you wanted to if you
were to leave this is what it would cost
to either have the tank dug up or if
there was an opportunity for the sale of
tank you wanted to buy the tank because
if you own your tank generally you can
shop around and have anyone fill that
tank the homeowner then would be
responsible for the maintenance on the
take unless you otherwise contracted out
for it what I see in the industry and
again we'll turn over if what I see is
not other people's experience but the
customer generally may not have that
original contract or maybe there wasn't
even an original contract to begin with
OR you bought the house from a developer
and the developer had a relationship
with the company and there's no
documentation
and so now you're stuck with node with
no documentation what what we were
looking at we still try and find that
documentation so we'll look to see like
did you pay tank rent at any time we try
and uncover who owned the tank and then
we try and resolve it on a case-by-case
basis because it is expensive to dig up
the tank resurface a fail there could be
damage to
um it's a heavy crane that sort of comes
in and so we really the propane
companies generally don't want to dig up
the tank we want to leave the tank in
the ground so it can be an arrangement
with another propane company you can
have that sort of conversation obviously
we're going to try and keep the customer
as much as we can we don't want them to
leave but I don't think there's a a
specific
industry on how it's done I think it can
be Case by case but what AmeriGas tried
to do to help clarify that since we had
so many acquisition customers was put in
our terms and conditions if you had an
underground tank and you wanted to leave
AmeriGas it was the customer's
responsibility if they wanted to if
AmeriGas wasn't going to buy the tank or
sell the tank to the customer that that
it would be the customer's
responsibility to dig up the tank and
that is where what I would say
specifically here in New Hampshire
because we've had a shortage of our
service tax and because some of those
service techs have been in bobtails we
have been behind although we haven't
been immediately offering to sell the
tank to the customer we also haven't
come out to dig it up and that's where
as mentioned prior is there may be
another scenario
um it's your you know you we own the
tank
um the relationship is so damaged that
you are very incentivized to to break
that relationship you may reach out to
an Eastern Sierra they can contact us
and we have historically not just here
in the state of New Hampshire in the
industry in general we can swap the tank
so they can bring us an asset like to
like asset
um so the competitor would still own
your tank we would transfer ownership of
that take ownership of a new underground
tank into our yard for use with another
customer
the gay representative votes has a
question but before uh in those we want
example 500 gallon underground tank
because the tank is the tanks the tank
all tanks the same
well it's no they're not all the same
and they're not all called the same
depending on where you live uh in the in
the United States
um but a 500 gallon any underground
asset is going to be more expensive
typically than the same size of an above
ground asset
um so you have that aspect of it there
are other safety requirements that come
with an underground tank there's
cathodic protection checks that's
incumbent upon the supplier to provide
uh for you as a as a customer so there's
there's variables in that and then
undergrounds can range anywhere from 100
gallon underground tank we have a lot of
those in the State of Florida and then
obviously where we have higher usage
here in new New England a typical
underground is a 500 or a thousand
gallon tank so you have tall risers I
mean the the refill point in the tank
there's shorter risers
um and various size and uh forms and
thank you following along this line of
questioning
is it possible to standardize the
process for
transfer of ownership of a tank from one
vendor to another
I've changed propane vendors four times
in the 16 years I've lived in my house
and each time the process for changing
ownership of the tank has been different
and from a customer point of view I
think that's that's confusing
it can sometimes be daunting to the
point where someone would would
not change vendors because of the
difficulty of exchanging the tank
so my question for you guys is
would it require legislation to set up a
standard process or is that something
that the industry would take on
second I'm going to speak for AmeriGas I
would say that is something that
obviously we would want the industry to
take on I know we have a lot of
gentlemen's agreements that we would
work through
um and so that it's clear but that's why
America's puts that in our terms and
conditions so you know what it would
what you would have to do if a customer
wanted to leave us they know at the time
of Contracting what our terms are and
what they would have to pay if they
would want to leave AmeriGas so we feel
we've already provided that within our
terms and conditions but I think to
again speaking for AmeriGas but then
speaking for the industry I think will
be something the industry would would
like to tackle first before seeing
legislation
uh I'm just going to ask a follow-up
question because as I indicated before
I've changed vendors four times I've
never received a contract from any of
the vendors to whom I have
changed or from whom I left
so I have no idea at this point in time
what
my status is with regard to my tank
I'm happy that the company comes and
fills it up periodically but beyond that
I I know nothing about my tank
um
I don't get charged a rental fee
but I do get charged a what they call a
safety fee every time they fill up my
tank and I have a question about that
for you later on but um my point here is
just to point out that
there is no
written agreement
that I'm familiar with I've done
business with
Eastern Propane with Suburban Propane
with Townsend energy they're my current
supplier
and with one other company whose name
I've forgotten already but um and I've
Leslie but I would I would still say we
would rather tackle that as an industry
which we can easily do here in New
Hampshire and and with the assistance of
of the trade Association as opposed to
having legislation I also think this is
where companies again now with a lot of
the online even though there is a larger
population is sending out that sort of
material getting contracts it makes a
relationship much more clear with the
customer so they know what the rights
and responsibilities are
representative minority has a question
so following up in the same line
we need to know how Divergent your terms
and conditions are from everybody else's
because it seems that everybody's got a
different
way they play in the sandbox and and
that's the problem we need to have
something more standardized and uniform
uh you know if if I have fuel oil and I
want to change a fuel oil distributor
not not a problem right but here it's
the tank it's the connection it's I mean
there's all sorts is there a contract is
there not a contract I've had lived in
the same home that I built 22 years ago
I never had a contract
no idea about a contract with an
underground tank
so there needs to be I guess what you're
hearing from us is standardized way of
the way you're going to do business so
people understand it plainly and clearly
is everybody going to have a contract
how's it going to work
how are you going to be able to change
from vendor to vendor if you want or
uh you could you could answer an hour or
you can answer later what would you
prefer okay cool
so that's a great question my name is
Leslie Anderson I am in charge of the
propane gas Association of New England
and
um
there are different terms throughout the
industry
um our industry is is made of companies
like AmeriGas that's the biggest in the
industry you know they're in all 50
states and then we have small
family-owned you know David Richard is
here he's not the small my typical small
I'd say a medium-sized company you know
that's family owned that's here but the
the companies offer different things
some companies offer 24-hour service if
your you know system goes down the
middle of the night they have somebody
that's going to be there in 30 minutes
to get it started and start working on
fixing it for you other companies don't
offer service you know and they might
have a lower price per gallon because
they have less overhead but there's a
wide variety of businesses out there and
it they also have different fees
depending on the type of customer how
many gallons they use the more propane
you use the less you pay per price per
gallon it's just like milk you know if
you buy a small thing of milk it costs
more per volume than it does if you buy
a gallon of milk at the grocery store
and if you're just using propane for a
generator you might have a minimum use
fee or a tank rental or tank usage fee
that you have to pay because you know on
a year like this you might only have
that generator running just for its
safety checks and and just for a day
during the year when the power goes out
and the company has got at least two
tanks there for a generator which is a
15 to 2500 asset that they are providing
at their expense that they are insuring
you know at their expense so the
homeowner doesn't have to and they have
to make up the cost of those tanks and
normally it's done in the price per
gallon some companies put all of their
fees into the price per gallon other
companies break it out and they say like
for a generator is a good example if you
only use 250 gallons you're going to
have to pay if you use less than that
you're going to pay a minimum use fee
for example and this number might vary
depending on the on the company and the
size of your tanks but if you go over
that that year then we're not going to
charge you a minimum use fee that year
because you're going to make it up in
your gallon age that you buy you know
and that's to the customer's benefit in
that case because if they didn't have
that they'd probably have to charge a
rental fee for those and you'd pay for
it every year whether you used a certain
amount or not
um so there's there is a wide variety
and the law that governs it first and
foremost is you know under the the UCC
your contract that you have with the
propane supplier if you don't have a
contract you know we we could say
everybody has to have a contract but in
a case like that then you're locking
people into contracts too so if you
don't have a contract in place and
you're not happy with the company that
you have then you should be able to
change to another company and I know
there was an issue here I listened to
the testimony when you guys beat Bob up
on that meeting that was saying it's
there and I apologize that I wasn't here
for that I cover Six States and I had a
big dinner meeting in in Massachusetts
that night that I had to be at but
um you know
I was like talking about um the
uh
oh yes yes but I'll offer to help
customers if they call them we have a
relationship with the AG's office and
the consumer protection group here and
they actually refer complaints that come
in to our office first and we reach out
to members of the propane industry
because we don't want to be you know
here having to testify against questions
that have come up we want to resolve
everything we want to have good customer
service as an industry so when I heard
the the testimony and and talked with
Bob I the next week I was at a meeting
with Michelle who runs uh the legal
department at AmeriGas and I said we
have got you guys have got a big problem
in New Hampshire how can we fix that you
know we have got to address this and
it sounds also like we need to make sure
that we are transferring takes in a
timely manner between companies when
people have underground tanks and they
want to change suppliers it's easier
with an above ground tank because the
new company can come right out and set a
new tank and they can connect you but
with an underground tank the company is
not going to deliver into somebody
else's underground tank that's not legal
you can't deliver into somebody else's
container that's in the state law you
know not for propane but just for
General container law but that's in the
state
so that gets the Crux of what I was I
was going to ask uh later on that there
is a Prohibition of you just can't say
Company B would you please provide
propane gas into into this tank that I
just fired company A4 they just can't go
in there and just start adding gas is
what you're saying not if the company
owns the tank so I have an underground
tank at my house not if the company owns
a tank I own the tank so I could change
tank companies tomorrow if I wanted was
there a is there a reason for that other
than it being a state like you said it
was a state law yes so it belongs having
some rsas available for from New
Hampshire would be helpful uh that
describes that
so that container belongs to a specific
company so they own the gas in it until
the customer is paid for that gas that's
delivered into it and they've also done
a safety inspection on that tank they've
done a pressure test to make sure
there's not any leaks from the tank
itself all the way into the line into
the house they've checked all of it so
there's our safety rules too that have
to be done when a tank is changed out or
when ownership has changed out and and a
new company comes they'll come inspect
the tank normally and do a pressure test
on the new system before they take them
without knowing that
the church and I apologize to
representative partial but he's been
waiting to ask a question so I'll defer
okay thanks for coming today
um now time here earlier that you told
me that you informed us a number of
these underground tanks you've acquired
through acquisition
I don't know
generally I would say generally speaking
yes I'm sure the number of tanks that we
have in New Hampshire were AmeriGas put
in the ground and we have a contract to
show that but just generally our company
has been one that has grown through
acquisition and we did a big acquisition
for example in 2012 where it almost sort
of doubled the size of AmeriGas and so a
lot of that we didn't always get the
customer records that came with
everything so in my experience when
these issues have come across my desk
it's generally where the customer was an
acquisition customer and we don't have
any underlying documentation if there's
documentation we always look to that
first
yes follow up please uh yes I'm looking
at your um Clause 14 here in terms of
agreement
and um it tells the customer that they
are responsible for all cause for the
excavation and removal of at least
equipment and companies not responsible
for Furnishing fill well it goes on but
it sounds like you've put a
responsibility of removal of an AmeriGas
tank entirely upon the customer am I
doing that correctly if there is no
underlying contract and we don't know
this was an attempt to try and get some
uniform policy together so there wasn't
this one-off every single time but
generally speaking this is what's here
so that customers could see it they
could say I don't want to accept your
terms and conditions of Airgas come get
your tank and we and they can reject
what these terms and conditions are and
we will come pick up the tank what has
happened again we were trying to in
light of not having underlying
documentation sort of putting it
together when we don't know what the
no more comment on that
you mentioned a scenario that is exactly
my
house it's
subdivision by the owner that built the
subdivision he kind of deal with the gas
company so all the tanks that are set in
he built this multi-million dollar home
that's in my subdivision
it's a nice subdivision but now that I'm
in the house 11 years old but we're
under that we're locked in there there's
no paperwork like you were saying
earlier so there's the only way out of
it is we would have to have the tank dug
up
or you could buy like that's what I'm
saying you would transfer the tank
whether it was AmeriGas would sell the
tank or the company that owned the tank
would sell the tank directly to you or
could sell it to it so they can you
still can do that there's no no
liability to whoever selling the tank
I'm assuming it would come with a bill
of sale and the liability would transfer
with the sale of the taxes yeah because
we've been talking about that since uh
for a year now about this because in the
lousy contract I used to say I think
it's a conspiracy because he gets his
gas probably for free if it's putting
these 17 tanks and
so um
I'll let you continue but uh I just make
a statement that it's uh absolutely we
here in New Hampshire you know about 80
percent of our businesses in New
Hampshire are small family-owned
businesses and we certainly wouldn't
want to put any restrictions or
regulations in effect that would affect
particularly family-owned businesses I
apologize if I'm not very sensitive to a
large corporation but we want to make
sure that we don't hurt our family-owned
businesses so
um uh it would be great if the
association perhaps to be a member of
the association they may want a few
things to be sterilized but I just want
to make that clear that that we're not
out to make any regulations here if we
don't have to because we know that will
probably affect the small family-owned
businesses the most and we don't want
that to happen
at least I don't anyway
um so if you please continue and when
when you're done with your
other information we can open it up to
maybe more questions involving
specifics and everything so so again
what I'll do to to bring into a close is
is go through a couple things one again
AmeriGas puts all this information in
front of our customer at time of
contract so they can try and make an
informed decision
um two we we
changed our business model to a more
centralized model and around on around
2019 and we had a little hiccups in the
road at that sort of
um the the transition particularly
during coved this particular year we
still have had some issues with driver
shortage and Tech shortage and then with
the change over and a number of our
customer experience agents answering the
phone we know we are we are working on
those things to address that so
specifically one we're continuing
training with the customer experience
agents we've taken all of the New
Hampshire calls and put them into a
separate queue so they're going to more
experienced agents so that those
resolutions so the customer's not saying
I called America so they're not calling
me back we want that one call resolution
so they really only have to make one
call we are always looking at our terms
and conditions to say can we do
something better are we disclosing as
much information as we can so the
customer can make an informed decision
and then here specifically understanding
the issue of the tank we've looked at
where we are are with our tank picks up
pickups so we are going to try and sell
or transfer ownership to the to the 26
tanks that we see right now that are
underground tanks in New Hampshire and
we've contracted with a third-party
company to pick up any of the above
ground tanks and then what we will do is
on your fact sheet we have all of the
contact information and specifically for
for our colleagues and our competitors
that they have that number to call with
Victor sproza the director of territory
operations so if they get a customer you
know if Easter gets a customer and they
say we want to switch from AmeriGas Bob
Young knows who to call so that process
should be much more streamlined and
that's what you're here in our
commitment today this is what we're
going to do we don't want to be back in
front of this committee again saying hey
AmeriGas made a mistake or we didn't put
our customers where we know they should
be this is really what we want to do
again we have almost 30 000 customers we
made I think almost 40 000 delivery
since October 1st to now we do have a
lot of really happy customers we want to
continue to have happy customers
um and so but we do have a couple things
uh that we're going to work on and you
have our commitment today that we're
going to get those done
so
um
I guess the main question is
when how soon and are some things
already in effect so some things are
already in effect so right now the again
with the calls going through we are
looking I get a daily report from the
vice president who's in charge of our
call centers to make sure I can see what
those New Hampshire numbers look like we
talk about it we have several meetings
internally to go through those numbers
and make sure we're we're hitting the
targets that we want to hit we have also
um one we've looked at our service order
and working with our service department
we've engaged at third party so I would
say for tank pickups probably 90 days I
just think with weather and with ground
and by contacting the customer we want
to make it so that it's convenient for
the customer
um who generally want to be there when
we go to pick up the tanks but from a
um any backlog of customer service
issues to me I think that's really 30
days if not sooner tank pickup I would
probably say probably 90 just given the
and representative from an operations
standpoint
um to add on to that we definitely
struggled with delivery Staffing for
much of the winter we are fully staffed
uh at this point in time from a delivery
standpoint
um essentially cleaned up on any
delivery backlogs uh across the entire
state in fact we were sitting uh better
than we happened several years in that
regard as well so
so I'm kind of curious
um unfortunately representative rung has
left the room but I suspect that the
I don't know that the packet that she
sent
she won't return
okay the packet of complaints but
assuming that she came she she comes
from Merrimack I'm assuming she's
collecting a lot of information from her
constituents in Merrimack have you found
right uh
also the AG list I was just kind of
wondering how how many of them came from
Merrimack like to see if there's maybe a
a a geographic or or Regional issue as
opposed to the rest of the state
I haven't seen that we I can take a look
at that and we can see if it is sort of
if it's a geographic issue as opposed to
maybe just a
um some other issue but I haven't seen
her specific facts
yeah they're they're just stats they're
not uh they're just complaints from
various companies
and um
yeah you're out there
tenfold at least but we do have a
specific tracking mechanism of every AG
complaint that we get by state so
certainly we have that detail
so but you haven't looked into it as far
as if you're coming so we have looked at
primary challenge I have looked at
specific complaints coming into
and then we also have again our it's
called a College ERM system
Mission management system so every time
a customer calls AmeriGas it's like a
note goes into the system that says
Michelle called in because she had a
question about tank rent or Michelle
wants to know what the price per gallon
is going to be for her delivery all of
those interactions get tracked in our
system so we can see so that's where any
agent if I were to call into America
they could see all the times that I've
called in or what my previous questions
were so I'm I'm pretty positive if those
complaints are there we would have a
yeah
thank you Mr chairman a quick question
on the especially when you brought up
rental fees and now I know that was
based on a lot of the complaints there
as well is um
what what is written or decides when a
person when the company owns a tank when
the people own the tank or especially
when they own it they're not when the
company owns it they're not paying
anything and then all of a sudden they
start getting charged rental fees what
changes from an ownership to uh uh well
they don't pay rental fees to what point
where they do
so generally speaking if it is a if if
the customer owns the tank they're not
paying any rental fees because they own
the tank they've either bought it from
another reseller or they bought it from
a propane company but if they own the
tank the car or at least I'll say
AmeriGas doesn't charge customers for
tank rent on tanks that they don't own
um if AmeriGas owns a tank it is uh it's
an asset of the company it's steel so we
charge a tank rent and at time of
contract you will you will be told so
again going to the various size whether
it's 100 pound cylinder or a 500 gallon
tank you will be told what your tank
rent charge is and that there may be a
CPI or other increase that is at time of
contract and so the customer will know
exactly what it is and the tank rent can
vary basically for Geographic reasons
maybe some competitive reasons or again
the size of the tank
where it gets where it can also be
different is through historic industry
practice I will say and Leslie spoke a
little bit there may be something called
a minimum use whereas if you're a high
volume customer the company May waive
tank rent because you're purchasing so
many gallons but if you're a low volume
usage um they may say okay if you only
are gonna buy 50 gallons you're going to
have a tank rent charge so different
companies will disclose if they disclose
it when tank right may be applicable to
you outside maybe that additional
contract so on here I think we have in
our terms and conditions I think it is
two times the volume of the tank so the
customer will know when they're if
they've triggered that where they've
used two times the volume of that tank
and a trail in 12 months so now they
know whether they're going to pay tank
rent or not based on the original
contract so again where it can get
confusing is if it's an acquisition
customer no one had a contract they
don't understand maybe the company has
waived tank rent if you call in and say
you know what you I had a late delivery
this year I don't think I should pay
tank right our agents are told you can
freely negotiate with a customer and you
can waive the tank rent for that year if
you want to waiver for the customer
particularly the customer says I may
leave so they're allowed to make
maybe missed it so
uh but I thought we'll talk about when
you have underground tanks you have to
you only fill tanks that are owned by
AmeriGas correct so in that case you
charge rent to every one of your
customers yeah
so and there could be a number of
reasons why we may not one is maybe at
the time of negotiation
they said we don't we don't want to pay
tank rent and America said okay we'll
still do business with you you're not
going to pay take rent or it is a
situation where we may not have that
background we may not know what was
negotiated at the time so we may say
because we don't know we're not going to
charge tank rent on that particular
customer or we do have a contract and it
says if you have the minimum use and you
meet those Minimus we won't charge you
tank rent so there could be a number of
reasons why on a AmeriGas owned tank you
may or may not have tank rent
I hate this first another follow-up I
got one quick I can
quick
um
sorry I'm sorry I apologize chair last
question is are the customers aware that
they of these different options they
have when they begin business with
marigas are they aware of their
different options and willing and
when we come in we have this sort of
scripts that go through sometimes maybe
it could be a a new customer package
where we'll wave tank rent for the first
year because you're a new customer those
sort of things we lay that out at the
time of contract of when you will get
tank rent and then that's what we also
put in the terms and conditions what
that tank run is attempting to cover
thank you but I I will also say
because of history and acquisitions
it may not be 100 completely consistent
but that is the goal of what AmeriGas is
trying to do at time of contract you're
told what take credit's going to be
sure thank you Mr chairman so my
question might best be answered by Ms
Anderson
do propane companies typically
require customers to sign a new contract
every year
I belong to a propane Co-op
that aggregates
a bunch of
gallonage and then goes out and talks to
a company about getting giving them a
special price for that gallonage
and those of us who are part of the
co-op have to sign a contract once we're
once we're offered that price
I've never noticed that that contract
says anything about the tank
it seems to be just about the propane
itself but my question for you is is
that fairly standard practice among
propane companies to require people to
sign a contract every year or is that
unique to my situation
so you normally will be signing a
contract if you are pre-buying your bet
your gallons a lot of people decide in
the summer to lock in their gallons and
pre-buy them uh because they're going to
cost less when they buy the Futures
historically not always but nine times
out of ten it's going to be more
advantageous of you to buy your gallons
in the summertime when gas is
inexpensive and lock it in for the year
and in that case you will have a written
contract the dealer is actually required
to put a bond of a certain amount down
to make sure that if they went out of
business you would still get your
gallons you know that's in so they're
going to have a written contract on that
and many of the companies included in
that contract will include the tank
terms that they have that are in there
previous to taking this position I was
in Michelle's position at Dead River
Company and wrote the contracts and we
had in there for underground tanks and
in the contracts that I wrote and we
would put it in the pre-buy contracts
we'd also put it in a fixed price
contract so we offer are fixed prices
where you pay a little fee to lock in
the Futures price on it your price won't
go up and if it goes down you get the
lower price so there's like four
different pricing options we had for
customers depending on how they wanted
to to buy their propane and when
um and in each of those we had
information in there about minimum use
fees and we also had information and
when they kicked in in that kind of case
they would kick in at a certain gallage
amount and we also had um underground
tanks in there and that if you decided
to change you would either have to help
pay to remove the tank from the ground
or you could buy the tank from us
that was in our contract
my follow-up question would be can you
explain to me what a safety fee is and
why
it has gone up fairly steadily over the
I'm not sure specifically what that
company is putting into their safety fee
I could find out for you if you can let
me know who the company is that's there
I would imagine if it's a safety fee it
might have to do with cathodic
protection on the tank when you have an
underground tank in specifically every
after 10 years you need to go out and
check it every year and make sure that
it's not rusting or having any any
problems it has adequate cathodic
protection in the ground for it it could
be related to DOT requirements that they
have an additional
um
requirements for delivering of Hazmat
Vehicles so I'm not specifically sure
what what they're lumping into that fee
I've also seen meter fees on some of the
bills
um that that people will have and have
come out and I think one of the things
that causes confusion is when there's
acquisition there's a lot of
Acquisitions in our industry and it
makes it confusing when you have a
company acquire another and that other
company might have been for sale because
they weren't doing so well maybe they
weren't doing so well because they
weren't charging minimum use fees on
some of their assets that were out there
you know and then they get bought and
the new company comes in and looks at
the book of business and says well these
accounts over here don't make any sense
you know we're going to have to change
how we handle those and then when
there's suddenly a new fee
um depending on how well that's
communicated it can cause some problems
for the for the consumer
so we do try to work with the AGS and
the consumer protection if people call
in and have a complaint they direct them
to our office we reach out to upper
management at our members have them
resolve it if they can and then if if
it's not successfully resolved it can go
back to the AG's office we also handle a
lot of calls in the winter time from the
governor's office where people will call
and a lot of times it's someone that's a
single mother they've got a kid they
can't afford to get heating you know
bills paid and how can somebody in your
Association help out you know and I'll
reach out to a member and they'll get
them signed up with LIHEAP or work with
them to get a delivery made and then put
them on a payment plan to work it back
so we handle a lot of calls and we try
to make ourselves available to the
places where people would go to complain
like the consumer protection and refer
them to us because we do want to make
sure as an industry that we have good
customer service
and making sure that it's easy for
people that with underground tanks to
transfer those tanks if they do have a
bad experience and want to change
companies is something that we will be
talking with our members about to make
sure that we have a best practices in
place and the industry members are all
thank you and I would also encourage you
to if you do develop these best
practices to share those with all
customers too so that those of us who
are
are buying the propane and maybe wanting
to change vendors will know what to
good
thank you Mr chair so
following up after what what a chairman
spoke about is a
I see a uh a big opening here for the
association to put together a template
of these are all the kinds of fees you
can expect in dealing with your gas
company whether it be tank fees safety
fees switch switching fees from one
company to another uh minimum use fees
what all all the whole bucket of the
universe it fees and and costs might be
in dealing with having gas as something
that you want to buy
then every company can
come in and fill in all right on this
master laundry list here's how we deal
with them
but that puts customers in the position
to be be able to say oh well if I go
this route
you know I I see all these things that I
have to pay or not pay as the case may
be and not be confused what we saw as
committee members was just this
unbelievable display of I don't get why
I'm getting all these fees and what's
happening to me and why I can't move
simply from point A to point B when I
used to be able to do it before
and it's because everybody's got a
different way of doing business and no
one knows what all these ways are
think if you
create such a a common template and you
can't put the fees on it because that'd
be antitrust issues but at least but at
least here are these the uh the terms
that may be relevant for the gas service
that you want to buy so that just any
customer wanting to make a change or
initiate a service would say okay it's
not as simple as going to the gas pump
at the gas station and putting the gas
in it's it's way more complicated than
that and including that that you know
there may be differences if you own a
tank or not own a tank or don't know if
you own the tank you know this is all
um thank you uh well it's exactly in
many ways it's exactly what I was going
to say but I was going to add that and
just thank you mayor gas for giving us
this information but I count 17 fees
right here in in their list of of
potential fees
um they they kind of explain what they
are and they give you the price that
that that you'll pay
um including if you want a paper copy
they're going to charge you almost three
bucks per invoice
um now I understand some companies may
not list as many fees like that but they
may have a higher price per gallon to
cover certain fees you may not even wait
you may not even be aware you're paying
for them but
um
getting back into what I think is time
we can start asking a few questions
are these fees
mandated or business driven or a
combination of both uh and is there any
way that we can
talk about those fees and why we have
them I guess you could say everything
costs money and rather than charge it
into a price per gallon we're just gonna
get them out or maybe these fees maybe
they may maybe most of them don't even
apply to people they're just there in
case
so can we have a little discussion on
that and also I I I I I know you're
giving us a presentation but we have
other Industries other companies here as
well maybe they might like to speak up
on on perhaps how they do business I
recognize AmeriGas you're quite large in
this state and you have certain
capabilities that you're talking about
that you're going to be doing this and
that and hiring people for that
our other family-owned business
businesses may not be able or may not be
doing that because you're much much
smaller so perhaps what are they going
to do or is there a industry standard at
least to be a member of your Association
no um
we don't have any any industry standards
set for fees themselves
um that there's people here I think it
would make sense for the other three
companies that have come today to talk
about the fees that they have so you can
have an overview of what it is I think
most companies try to address it in the
price per gallon put all their costs
into that for delivery and then some
companies I think add additional fees
because they don't apply to everyone so
it may be more beneficial overall for
their consumers to only be charged if it
applies to them uh so it's it you know
it's all competitive and driven by the
marketplace so we're not regulated at
all in terms of fees
um
is there would
if you don't mind would some other
company like to come up and say a few
words where you don't have to if you
don't want to we're just extending the
invitation
good afternoon
I'm Debra show with do you appreciate
Angie and Dover
well thank you
um well I I guess I'll start with uh
like I said AmeriGas offered like 17
fees I won't go over each one of them
but uh what what drives some of your
fees and uh are there are there some
federal mandates are there some State
mandates are there some business
uh needs I mean can you describe a
little bit about how your company does
it mostly it's uh based on the cost of
doing business but primarily our our
company in Dover we only have one fee
and we don't have any other delivery
fees Hazmat fees it's just if we have a
generator account it's a usage fee and
those tend to be very sporadic sometimes
you can have power outage and you go
through propane in a day or two
sometimes they don't have any power
outages and you don't have a delivery
for three years so that's what we have
to accommodate for the cost of Steel it
is skyrocketed over the last two or
three years it's gone up triple so
typically we just started doing uses
fees but we have to accommodate for that
increased cost to be able to give that
tank out as a loaner suit to get some
recoup on that on that asset
so does that mean that it's if someone
uh is transferring over to your company
uh
you would have to remove the other
company's tank
um primarily no most of the time we have
an agreement so say
um customer will call into our company
they are just expressing a desire to
change companies because of some unknown
reasons and whatnot so they call in we
send out a sales rep to go out and take
a look at the tank over the in and the
um the house to make sure there is no
glaring issues as far as liabilities and
whatnot so if that checks out
um we'll move forward in taking down the
serial number and whatnot of the tank
itself and we will have the customer
call and express a uh that they have to
verbalize that they want to change and
then at that point we will contact that
company with the serial number and it's
as simple as that they will produce a
invoice and charges for that company
questions
off the topic anyway yeah so thanks very
much my question
um and first congratulations I see
you're very highly rated with the state
of New Hampshire oh thank you 91 years
in business uh since 1932. so that's a
good one
um tell me um
do you have problems with fulfillment
due to labor shortages drivers well ex
we're all experiencing some type of
challenges right now with the labor
market and um
it is a known fact and we're trying to
work with a lot of votechs right now and
trying to entice young people to come on
board within the trades instead of going
to a four-year color so we're trying to
be a little creative with that right now
do you well
one one the obvious question then would
do you find that because of this labor
shortage are you uh are your customers
experiencing prolonged delays and
deliveries or anything like that no
we've we've got a great Labor Force
we've got a lot of gentlemen at work a
lot of hours and they're very dedicated
a lot of them have been been with us 20
30 years and we don't want them to age
out we're really stressed out about that
right now so we're trying to get the
younger generation to come up through
it's too much
this is just a quick mathematical
question and this is ties to the all the
fees so just looking at the Hazmat fee
which is just be on the safety and
safety compliance and thank you AmeriGas
for providing the number of customers
you have because that helped out the
math 29 632 customers at this fee which
is each each fill up and I know
everybody's not going to filter tank
twice but I'd say it's probably about
the average per year
um seven million dollars for the
residents of New Hampshire per year to
just for safety fee so um
oh I guess my question is is
um
is this where the profit is made is off
there may be reasons why you know
depending on it is generally charged for
delivery but sort of like tank thread
sometimes these fees get waived
customers customers to call in so I
don't know what the exact daughter or
the number of New Hampshire customers
that can't
follow up real quick
can that so the Hazmat fee is that can
that be negotiated to be excluded as
well
okay
after that so uh sounds obvious but I'll
ask anyway so in my case I get anywhere
from four to five Phillips a year one of
the start of the season and one of the
end of April and I'm on my own after
that
um so would that be would that Hazmat
charge be charged for each one of those
Phillips
foreign
have customer changeovers uh are any
kind of difficulties in the tank
changeouts what not how do you deal with
anymore
and if they can't produce that
information
thank you
is
we can't fight
thank you
yes
so we've spoken to marigas already and
now we're speaking uh
um to someone different are you an
AmeriGas dealer
no Okay so
if there was some kind of a standard in
place
maybe not a legal standard but a a best
practices standard developed by the
propane Association would you find that
something that you would
find advantageous to follow or do you
think you need
because of your own unique customer
circumstances you need to develop your
own process for doing things like
so this question is a general question
uh
primarily to the association but maybe
anyone else so as I look at these fees
here
that from what we heard in testimony
that that
the purpose of the bill
was going to be if we needed a study
committee to discuss
fees what they are why they're needed
and why they vary in costs so much
so this is an opportunity to perhaps
discuss that issue
in terms of
one company says they don't charge those
fees the other company says they they
charge them it's like a you know LMO
type of thing
um but I also hear that whether you
charge them
outwardly or not
they all get rolled up into the price
that you're charging for your price per
gallon or are there fees that companies
honestly
do not charge because they do not incur
but if they didn't incur them would they
charge them I mean uh I'm just trying to
figure out if if
we can ask the question are these fees
Justified and you could read right here
and say Well they're Justified because
you say they are
um but do other companies
would they also charge these fees if
they had to do the same thing that's was
listed here I guess that's what I'm
trying to say now more a question for
the probing Association I think
I think those these are
probably the majority of companies roll
the fees all into their price per gallon
um and then we have Eastern Propane here
and I've talked with them about fees
before I don't know if you guys want to
come up and talk about how you how you
handle it
um but it's just a different business
model
you know some companies lay it all out
and but the majority of them put it all
I think into their their gallon fee and
then they might have a few fees for
exception you know like generators
accounts things that are unusual
um and would would not fit the normal
so
at the risk of not trying to sound trite
um does that mean that if they roll
their fees into the price of their price
per gallon does that mean customers are
I don't really understand the question
because I think some companies are just
breaking out their business models so
there are costs associated with Hazmat
licensing and DOT requirements there's
tests that have to be done and and for
safety reasons and different things so I
think some people are just breaking it
down in their
bill you know and others are just
putting it all into one fee or one cost
in the price per gallon so it's I think
it's kind of like getting an itemized
Bill versus getting just a grand total
well okay I understand that but um
uh certain things like a reconnect
charge wouldn't apply if you didn't get
reconnected uh but I wouldn't think that
a company would I hope companies not
charging that fee as part of their price
per gallon even though they're not
reconnecting
yeah so
I guess we're just trying to determine
if we need to study these fees uh
further I'm I'm hoping we don't but
that's what I'm trying to get answers
here but I'll leave that question like
for the time being and defer to our next
can you shed some light on uh how you
um yes as I kind of suspected something
like that I just wanted to hear what
people had to say What's a what's a
anything
thank you Mr chair I'm still a little
bit confused about this question of
rolling up fees into your price per
gallon wouldn't that put you in a
competitive disadvantage to people who
shop based on the price per gallon
can you elaborate on how that would
Ms Anderson could you explain a little
bit more about what rolling fees and to
the price per gallon is all about I'm
still confused about that
well I think I was just trying to
explain what some of the companies are
calling different fees so you heard the
meter reading fee and that is the extra
cost for going out and checking the
meter at a location
um
there's also I've seen some you
mentioned a safety fee that might be
also a Hazmat fee that I've seen which
covers additional expenses for training
drivers and DOT requirements that have
come in you know it's a lot harder today
to get a driver on the road than it was
even a year ago and
some companies I think are addressing
these by individualizing those line
items so they may have had a price per
gallon and then the cost of business
keeps going up you know um I've seen on
my own bills not from propane companies
but sometimes I get a delivery fee when
the price of gasoline or diesel gets
high you know so I think it's along the
lines of that when there's a new
surcharge or something that comes in
that the company is is trying to make up
the expense of that program through the
use of a fee
and then other companies like like
Eastern have decided that they're going
to have one price and they're not going
and this isn't this is added onto fees
it was one of the complaints in the bill
and but it's not mentioned on here is
the minimum fill fees so I'm speaking
from personal experience if you have a
500 gallon tank
the minimum required for the company I
have is 250 gallons to fill it but if
and it's hard to tell because you have a
percentage meter on your tank so you
don't really know what's exactly in
there so I only need 220
I still get charged for 250. so an extra
30 gallons I'm getting charged I'm not
actually using do you do practices like
is that normal for you to do that as
um
looking at this complaint sheet here
that the you know stature uh you uh you
didn't get the trophy but you're in
second place uh can you make uh are you
aware of of them and and and know what
actions you might want to be taking if
if any or we have no idea we have no
idea of knowing how old these complaints
are that's unfortunately we don't know
but uh but are you aware of of of of
many of them
um so I have a general question uh
the way the industry is run here even
Nationwide I'm assuming and we're
talking we're talking only propane here
right now anyway right so uh
it's like a commodity so
it is volatile the the price is volatile
but not every so um
is that why we have a lot of um
number one a lot of different
ways companies handle their business
um uh one standard way may not fit a
model because of the volatility of of
say propane gas up or down or does that
play into why our propane industry
business model is kind of like the way
it is right now as opposed to
some other you know firm of say let's
say
I don't know much of oil oils the same
ways oils volatile as well but but just
the the market itself because of the
fossil fuel type of upsells everything
is that why we have all these different
probably more to do with companies that
operate in multiple States I think you
you pointed out that there's a lot of
fees on amerigasa's terms but they
operate in 50 states so they're trying I
think to have a contract that covers all
of those 50 states as well where it
probably a smaller company wouldn't have
those and propane is the least volatile
of all of the the delivered fuels it's
stayed the most the steady you know and
prices are down from last year there's
an excess of propane there's more
protein produced every year than is ever
used globally around the world you know
and a lot of it is just flared off and
wasted so the use of it is really a
great way to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions because you're either using it
or you're you're flaring it off anyway
um it's I think it's just about the way
companies do business and the difference
that that exists between a small company
and a larger company
thank you
um I don't know that oil is necessarily
standardized in oil
delivery the customers own their own
tanks so a customer can call one company
one day in another company the other day
um and as long as the company can get
out and probably do an inspection most
of them require that to make sure that
everything's hooked up right they're not
going to just pump it into somebody's
basement then
um
there's a lot more freedom and there's
more competition also there's more
heating oil companies out there than
there are propane companies because the
propane requires a much larger
investment you have to invest 150 000 in
your first truck and you have to invest
in tanks to to put out to supply because
to get customers the dealers frequently
Supply the tanks um and that keeps the
customer from having to have that big
investment you know to to buy a tank on
their own
um and
it does make the changing a little
harder because the companies have to
coordinate and and transfer the assets
of those tanks uh when that happens but
I think that's the main the main
difference that there is between propane
and and heat oil
yeah
you have feet there are a lot of Feeds
out there for heating oil also for
it just depends on the company it's the
same thing but there's there's companies
that have delivery charges and Hazmat
fees and safety fees for oil deliveries
that's curious what's the lifespan of a
tank
the lifespan of an in-ground tank it
depends on the type of soil that you
have and everything but there's tanks
that are out there 50 60 70 years
um I think we have granite in the state
so I think that you'd want to be
checking it every year if your tank is
over 20 years old for sure the
recommendation is to go to cathodic
protection at 10 10 years to get it
cathodically protection tested uh and
and then they can add anoids to it if
they need to
um is that something that the company
would do on their own without even you
even knowing about it
uh they they might call to coordinate to
let you know they're going to be out you
know in your backyard with wires and
checking to make sure your tank is okay
so they probably would coordinate to let
you know that they're coming to do that
but yes companies they have an asset in
the ground that they want to maintain so
they're going to be out there doing that
uh that being said uh above ground tank
on the coast in salt conditions is going
to be changed out a lot free more
frequently than it's it's lifespan a lot
a lot of the companies change those out
every five years just because they start
to rust and they take them back and they
refurbish them and and get them cleaned
up and ready for reuse and against it
since if the company owns tank they
they're responsible to replace it on
their own and everything if if need be
it's a technique used to control the
corrosion of a metal surface by making
it the cathode of an extra
electrochemical cell
so it's a test that you do to
intact that that it's still structurally
yes you're testing to make sure the
cathodic protection system is in place
and operating correctly because if you
don't have cathodic protection in place
then you're going to have degradation of
the steel in the ground because it's in
contact with the soil and with a you
know groundwater potentially with
different minerals so when you install a
tank you put in a cathodic protection
and it's if you fish and you have anodes
on your boat that you throw over in the
salt water it's the same same idea as
that
um do you want to explain it better you
probably have more serious experience
over typical 500 gallon tank in New
England
a cloth bag or a
metallic bag what
yeah
so it's not just a test it's an actual
system that's been installed installed
and you check the system and if it's
today
um
new installation to start right from
that get all the older ones so if your
tank was installed before 2014 it
okay thank you oh
is a homeowner
entitled to ask the propane company to
look at all of the tests and times if
yes
would any other industry experts like to
come up and speak at all you you have
I'm Daniel with white Mountain Oil in
North Conway and um I just want to I
mean I don't want to talk about Hazmat
fees and all the other fees because we
don't really we have a meter read fee
um
but I just wanted to reassure everyone
that there really is an industry
standard with trading tanks that's
something I've been doing for more than
40 years and uh and it's worked
seamlessly
uh AmeriGas had some communication
issues which they have talked about and
they're going to address but other than
that with the guys that are in this room
and the 17 other companies that I deal
with trading an underground tank is
it's very is simple and there are serial
numbers on the tank and sometimes with a
customer who says they own their own
tank I relate it to like a vin number on
a car if you can show me the VIN number
if you can show me the purchase we're
fine but
if not the propane companies keep track
I
very rarely I I can't even think of an
instance where we've put up both those
are in somebody's yard and dug up attack
it's always done on paper it's usually
an invoice or the other procedure is um
I mind oh Eastern a tank
so instead of they instead of selling it
we'll drop a new tank off in their yard
or we'll give them a permission to pick
up a tank
from FW Webb and Bill us so that's how
it's done it's done on paper and we all
get along fine
um one of the things I love about this
business is we I say we fight on the
streets but we all meet at the bar at
the end of the day and tell War Stories
so there hasn't been a problem trading
tanks and a customer should I used to be
here for us not anymore I just I just
want to reassure you that the consumer
shouldn't feel that they're trapped with
these Underground
not in my experience and I'll answer
any questions
okay
North country doesn't have any problems
I can give you my card we go to Twin
Mountain
uh thank you very much I appreciate it
um uh
anybody else would like to say a few
words
I'm sorry I thought I saw some getting
up
okay well uh with that being said uh
let's review what AmeriGas has said
would you summarize in a commitment to
the state of New Hampshire what you
are currently doing and what you plan to
do and when you plan to get there
activities
question could you uh give us a supply
of business cards so that we can contact
you if we have any issues we can't
resolve for constituents
so uh now this might be highly unusual I
don't know
um I I haven't been in this position for
you know 30 years but uh may I ask uh Mr
Skelly uh there is going to be a point
in time uh this spring I'm sure our
committee is going to be handling some
Senate bills and we'll be meeting at
some time man can I ask you to come back
at some time probably in the May time
frame and uh perhaps you can give us an
update on what's what has happened I'm
not going to ask anyone else to come
back here but perhaps if they can go
through you and you can just come back
and
even offline or or we'll we'll reserve
some time maybe five minutes and you can
just let us know
um what the you know how far they've
gone
I
what's this
that's that's entirely up to you but
thank you for that yes and I just might
state that um I I
I know the representative from Merrimack
I would I would look into the Merrimack
issues first if you would because I have
a feeling that if nothing changes we
might be looking at an a a different but
similar Bill next year so
um that's my you know I think
obviously Merrimack has some is a center
of some of these complaints it would
seem because it comes from one person
but um you know that's just
that some people won't let this go away
if it's not corrected that's all I'm
saying yes
the record I live in Merrimack that's
right
thank you very much
blew up here from Florida and
Pennsylvania and he's members of the
geographic we're out in the state of the
camp here and the other
200 plus you know fuel deals 30 propane
folks just like these people in the room
stayed in the campus way thank you for
I guess I'll give the association a
chance to speak and see if if you're
um I I think that you had some excellent
recommendations and I'm going to take
those back to my members to talk about
how we can make these fees more
understandable
and explain what they are more
transparent to the customers so I will
bring that back to my members in New
Hampshire and we will definitely discuss
it
I think yeah
I'm sure we'll hear that in may as well